hello everyone and welcome to another
excellent game from the 2019 fede World
Cup it's the second game of the match
between the two of them so around 2.2 l
star safar lee now with the white pieces
against nikhil serene as someone
corrected me in the previous video said
it's not pronounced sorry in its serene
so if that person was not trolling me i
will pronounce it serene from now on so
Nihal having an excellent tournament so
far three straight wins in a row and i
misspoke in the previous video we had a
where and had the white pieces I said
that it was a part of the training camp
with Vladimir Kramnik I don't know how I
said it or why I was pretty sure I read
it somewhere in there I saw a photo of
him with kramnik but then after I kept
reading yesterday he was invited to this
training camp but he was not there
that's what I read and just base India's
website but ok sorry about that I did
not want to mislead you or anything I
just really thought he was there so that
being said let's check this game out
really exciting game all hell already a
lot of you suggested it even though it's
just finished but again for very good
reasons and it's hard to make so many
videos how much you guys are suggesting
but you know keep at it
so efore by Safari we have E 5 93 Knight
to c6 and Bishop to c4 the Italian game
is on the board with Bishop to c5 and as
Safari lost the previous game what do
you play when you absolutely have to win
of course you go for the Evans gambit
and yes it was played in this game so
let's see and I was very interested when
I saw this everyone tweeted about it as
soon as it happened as you don't see a
demon's gambit there very often in such
a high level chess and even though I'm
pretty sure like Annie Hall really knows
a lot of chest theory but it's always
exciting to see how much someone knows
about the Evans gambit so he went in for
the main line Bishop capture son before
we have c3 white is ready to grab the
center would be for Bishop to a5 and now
d4 with d6 he's not interested in
some pawn grabbing activities as he if
you know he needs a draw in this game to
advance in defeated World Cup into the
third match so with these six and now
Queen to b3 the standard idea going
after the f7 pawn and now Queen to d7
Queen to e7 is also possible but Queen
to d7 is the mostly played move with
castles by Safari now there's no pin
here on the c3 pawn and now Busher back
to b6 again a standard idea against the
Evans gambit you you vacate the a5
square for the knight so you can go
after the this double attack against the
Queen and the bishop with Knight B to d2
and now Knights the a5 as planned and
here you could go Queen c2 queen bee one
Anejo chooses Queen to be one and now
nickel doesn't go for the bishop right
away he leaves it there and goes the
knight to e7 he prepares castling and
now D captures on e5 with Knight the e7
e ha basically gave up a pawn so he can
get his King to safety in time so he
castles and Bishop to b5 this is a new
movie in the position ECAD for sun b6
there is a game from 2017 where this was
played but Bishop to b5 it's a new move
by Safari and well it seems like he was
he came very well prepared so let's see
how many nickel deals with it with c6
attacking the bishop bishop back the d3
now so it seems that the light square
bishop will survive this skirmish on the
Queen side and now rook to d8 and as you
don't want your Bishop on d3 here safari
offers a nitrate here to transfer the
bishop back to this useful diagonal with
nitrous on c4 Bishop captures and now
Knight to g6 just ready to capture this
pawn on e5 rook to d1 preventing capture
as the d6 pawn is now pinned and the
Queen to g4 now and here we have rook
captures on d6 now of course Safari is
hoping for rook captures and pawn
characters were white would have a very
strong past deep on but Nihal not
interested in giving him that and you
don't really have a good way of
developing your lights for gosh appear
to this square is covered by the rook
and the bishop discovered by the pawn so
first look to f8 and it all is forced to
retreat for the time being Queen back to
b3 now again putting pressure on the f7
pawn and now Knight to f4 and her only
hull forces a trade here as he's
threatening mate on g2 with Bishop
captures on f4 and Queen captures on f4
and now
well rook a to d1 seems like a logical
move and there there's nothing wrong
with it but Safari has a different idea
he please rook to d3
he needs the free the d6 square because
he wants to push east six and he can't
do that while the rookies on d6 because
of Queen captures on d6 so Bishop to g4
Nihao takes this opportunity to develop
his light-square bishop also the rooks
are now nicely connected and now e six
this is what's a far leap land with F
captures on e6 sorry wrong Bishop
captures on e6 with check and now King
back to h8 we have bushel captures on g4
and now nihill doesn't recapture right
away the Queen captures on e4 is
stronger as it grabs the pawn while
still leaving the option of capturing
the bishop because the rook on d3 is
also under attack
so rook the d7 and now meeting the Queen
captures on g4 with Knight to e5 but
this has to be played so clean capture
Sun g4 and now Knight to e5 and here
already it's somewhat unpleasant for
black facing this a knife to f7 check
and you you have to be careful capturing
on f2 is well mostly always a good idea
but not here here if you capture with
Bishop captures and f1 oh sorry Bishop
captures an f2
the King will just move away King the h1
and now your queen is still under attack
and well the knight is threatening to
come to f7 and also you have to be
careful of any smothered mates in your
coming your way so here if you move the
Queen for example Queen to h4 you're
still getting nice to f7 check and now
well you have to capture it and the
white just win the material otherwise if
you don't capture it you go
to the well-known line of the nicest
modern maid tonight checks a double
check from the Queen and the night king
has to move and of course you sacrifice
the Queen but for a good reason it's a
knight of seven checkmate
so here you don't capture on f2 you just
move the Queen Queen to f4 it's
important to keep an eye on the f7
squared to avoid any a loss of material
or or a smothered mate but still Knight
to have seven check with King to g8 and
here white could grab a draw if you
wanted to well of course he doesn't if
he draws he's out of the competition so
nice the d6 check first with King back
to a trade and now roped f1 now again
putting another defender CDF to pawn and
again you could capture here there's
nothing all that much wrong with it now
but still there for King to h1 you
haven't really achieved all that much
and I have your Bishop is stuck there so
instead Nihal decides to get rid of any
made threats with h6 create some
breathing room for the king here and now
kink the h1 not allowing this to come
with check and now indeed if you went
for this pawn here with Bishop
characters now knife to f7 check is it
deadly after king king goes here Knight
g5 you open a discovery King h8 96 now
nicely Forks the Queen and the rook and
you will of course lose material here
and the game so after King h1 we have
looked fsx a nice root lift preparing
the other look to come over to f8 and
now comes Knight to c4 and here what do
you play here here's an a very
interesting position because Knights the
c4 is actually a losing move for Safari
Nijo has a winning idea here so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this winning idea and it's not a simple
idea so you know be careful so for those
of you who were able to do it in those
few seconds congratulations you are an
excellent finder of incredibly difficult
ideas and for those who just want
enjoyed show the movies looked eh
because now that you've seen it of
course you realize that the White has a
lot of back ranked weaknesses and Queen
captures and f2 is
such a deadly threat you can't really
defend against it just show an idea if
you go for let's say a knife capture
something v6 for some reason just win
characters an f2 wins the game on the
spot and now you don't really have a
good move if you capture just a rocky
one check here and mate or if you don't
capture it you don't really have a
better move if you move the rook win f1
check again will mate if you go here
then Queen captures King captures and
now look the e1 is again made this row
covers the f2 square so after rook to e8
obviously you can't play some silly
moves and it's hard to make a move if
you move the Queen you lose the night
here so how can you defend against this
capture well it's not easy for example
you could try something like rook to d2
just adding more defenders to the f2
pawn but now Bishop captures an f2 comes
and now again white is without a move
you can't move the knight because your
rook is hanging you can't move the Queen
because the knight is hanging if you try
capturing here then after all the trades
that rook e1 is still mate so not
possible you could try Queen B 1 which
leaves the night you know free for
capture and hopefully you can give up
the night for the bishop here and you
can do this but this is with the
absolute best defense from white for
example Queen captures on c4 now I play
rook captures here and after captures
captures you will get Queen captures on
c3 and now of course the thread is a
rook e1 check to pick up the Queen you
will block it rook f1 but now after all
is said and done black is up two points
in a winning position two points is
enough here to go for the win you will
walk with b5 you know just push a 5 a 4
B 4 so start pushing the pawns and white
will always have to take care of the
bank the back rank so rook to e8 an
excellent winning move here but it was
not played in the game here any help lay
the Bishop captures on f2 first he
probably said ok we'll just play rook e8
next it's probably the same but it's not
here he allows white to this Knights - D
- and now the night after the knight
comes to f3 the F file is a block away
from the Queen rogue battery and
you will not be able to use any of the
trickery we've just shown so here we
have Queen to g4 Queen to g4 Nick I'll
play this he attacks the rook here but
the real idea is he wants to bring the
rook to g6 and threaten mate on g2 white
said all right rook captures on b7 and
here Nico has to play Queen to e2 with
Queen to d2
he's still better the game continues and
he enjoys his position but he played
rook to g6 a bit prematurely as okay
he's threatening mate now but now it's
actually white who has a winning
position rook to g6 is a big blunder and
I don't know if you all if you see why
it's a blunder immediately you should
but just in case you don't I will give
you a couple of seconds pause the video
and try to find the winning idea for
white in this position so for those of
you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
supporter of hanging bishops and for
those who just won't enjoy the show
by playing rook g6 Nichol actually left
the bishop on f2 hanging and the problem
is safari just captured it and now while
capturing it the g2 point is also
defended so there is no mate so here in
a better position and he'll just drop
the piece so really really a tough break
for him and then he had an incredible
run up until this point and even here
facing the evans given but he was
extremely low on time at at the moment
this move was played this rook to g6
that we mentioned he had like 55 seconds
on the clock so I mean that's I mean you
face the Evans gambit you will spend a
lot of time trying to calculate
everything out but okay
I mean I'll still continue in the game
King age 7 he doesn't want rugby 8 to
come with check but now Knight to f3
blocking and now rook to e8 still hoping
for for some you know trickery if
possible with Queen to be one pinning
the rook here and now rook to e3 and
here okay there are still some poison in
the position if white makes for like a
really silly move or something like
Queen b3 you can still win the game with
Queen captures on f3 for example now if
rook captures rook e1 is mate if you
play G captures then a rocky one check
rook f1 rock cap
is mate the route covers the G to square
but of course safar Li didn't didn't
play anything like this he played rook
to be four attack Nichols Queen we have
Queen to East six now getting out of the
way and here so far we'll just play rook
to f1 now there are everything is nicely
protected there are no more tricks here
white is up a whole piece and it was in
this position that Nichols evene
resigned the game as he's down a whole
piece so a really really tough break and
although it's a it's a tough break for
him I'm still I'm still glad that
someone someone played the Evans gambit
and who won a game with the Evans gambit
because history will remember that
between two grandmasters at the Evans
gambit was played and a white won a game
yeah tough loss for a young Annie Hall
but a great victory for the Evans gambit
and for elder so far Lee also of course
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Vivek
Takara for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Phaedo World Cup which
you all seem to enjoy so much checking
up on your lovely suggestions as usual
and and so on so thank you I will see
you soon have an excellent rest of your
weekend